massés sur un bateau une quarantaine de
migrants navigue en direction de la
petite île italienne de lampedusa ces
images ont été tournées par l' agence
européenne de garde-frontières et de
garde-côtes frontex chargée de la
gestion des frontières extérieures de
l'espace schengen cette technique de
surveillance aérienne est aujourd'hui
très critiqué par des ong humanitaires
qui accuse l'agencé de l'union
européenne d'utiliser ces moyens de
reconnaissance en méditerranée pour
repérer des embarcations de migrants et
prévenir la libye afin qu'elles puissent
les intercepter et ainsi empêcher les
navires humanitaires de secourir ces
personnes des moyens aériens de lieux
sont mises en oeuvre pour repérer des
navires de migrants puis pour guider les
soi-disant garde-côtes libyens vers les
bateaux cherchant à leur échapper
cette surveillance aérienne à mener à la
capture de dizaines de milliers de
personnes et à leur retour dans la zone
de guerre libyenne lors d'opérations qui
ne représente rien moins qu'un trafic
d'êtres humains et pratique
l'union européenne est accusé d'avoir
manqué à son devoir de sauvetage des
migrants en mer selon les ong
si ces embarcations de fortune sont
repérés par frontex
ces agents avaient retiré de leur
présence que les gardes-côtes de tripoli
même si des bateaux de ong humanitaires
ou d'autres navires se trouvent dans la
zone des accusations rejetées par l'
agence de surveillance de l'union
européenne qui revendique avoir
contribué au sauvetage de plus de trois
cent trente mille personnes ces
dernières années alors que le corona
virus a immobilisé les navires
humanitaires dans les ports italiens
pendant plus de deux mois
les embarcations reprennent
progressivement la mer avec l'arrivée de
l'été
l' agence européenne de gardes-frontière
prévoit une multiplication des
tentatives de traversée au cours des
prochaines semaines